alright John Perry here we're back happy
wetness day today we are going to find
out the identity of this fascinating
beast this beautiful creature this is a
turkey vulture so congratulations to all
you kids that got that one right
your names are in the video description
sorry I'm pre recording today so I
couldn't I don't have the power of
seeing into the future so I don't know
who actually guessed this right but your
name is in the video description so go
check that out really cool animal turkey
vultures are great we have two of them
at the Wildlife Center two of them that
are permanently there we get injured
ones in from time to time as well and oh
man there they are the best they are my
favorite super cute little guys we have
a bunch of new people that are playing
the game now and so I kind of wanted to
do an easier one last week's was a
little bit difficult you know we've done
quite a few difficult ones lately so
when I do an easier one for you look at
this creature this is actually the first
skull that I ever got and if you've been
watching my videos for a long time
you've already heard me talk about this
guy he's never been on what's at
Wednesday but I do talk about this skull
from time to time this is the thing this
is one of the things that really got me
interested in biology was just having
this around all the time to look at and
study it is one of the cleanest
specimens that I've ever seen it's just
super well preserved and my favorite
thing about it is that some of the teeth
come out check this out look at that
there's a molar for you one of his
molars and then one of these I think
it's this one right here this one comes
up so cool I love seeing how teeth are
structured and what fascinating
structures teeth are we just taken for
granted but they I mean your teeth stay
with you your entire life if you treat
them well and they're just they're just
his hard things in your mouth you know
but they get they are so important to us
and actually you know it's really neat
when you start looking at skulls and you
realize just how important teeth are cos
look at look at the perfect dental
occlusion that's you know the way that
bite the the bite works in an animal
these these teeth in the back here they
work like scissors they've got some
scissor like cutting that they can do
and then they also work to crush so this
thing is animal actually there's a hint
it probably eats meat and that's why it
has these scissor-like teeth and it
probably eats other things that are not
meat which is why it has crunching
molars
really cool animal super beautiful I
like I just love this skull yeah I've I
know it's weird but I've spent hours
looking at this thing studying it like I
said is the first school that I had it's
the first thing that got me interested
in skull Anatomy you know I learned what
a zygomatic arch is on this I learned
what a sagittal crest is by looking at
this thing yeah I learned what
turbinates are turbinates or the little
things inside the nose that they
actually what they're for is when you
breathe out water condenses on those
because you know you breathe out wet air
and water will actually condense on
those are covered in flesh when the
animal is alive
water will condense on those then get
absorbed into your bloodstream through
the just a really thin membrane that's
surrounding those bones and that helps
you not dehydrate and actually don't
know this but I imagine it's also useful
for the sense of smell
anyway fascinating skull I really love
this guy these are the ear bones you can
see that he's got a pretty dang big
brain really really cool critter what
could this fascinating beast be what's
it Wednesday let me know in the comments
section know googling
you